icon
legend
all-time great Garth Brooks has simply
put one of the most successful recording
artists and performers in history
born in Tulsa Oklahoma
Garth got his start singing in dive bars
and clubs before releasing his first
album in 1989 that album was just the
beginning as Garth would go on to become
the best-selling solo artist of all time
with over 148 million albums sold his
generational talent helped make Garth
the only artist in music history to
receive seven diamond album Awards which
commemorates over 10 million in sales
for each album blending country music a
rock and roll Flair and captivating
storytelling Garth is known worldwide
for his stunning live shows a unique mix
of the intimate that's spectacular
and above all an unmatched gratitude for
his fans
he remains the only artist to win seven
CMA Entertainer of the Year awards and
he continues to sell out shows all over
the world
Garth Brooks is undeniably a living
legend and the best part is he shows no
sign of slowing down y'all
his legacy only continues to grow vinyl
and also you're like the smartest
businessman ever because you can't catch
your new sukira so this is amazing
these are the weird thing was we you
know we went over razor babies yeah but
it came back vinyl was coming back and
you got you got to be kidding me right
and it's so cool but then you start to
look at pieces right so you collect
vinyl yes you know they cost 29 bucks 39
for for a piece of vinyl yeah so we got
with a company that had plants all over
the world and said make me a box if you
can where people can pick it up for a
great cost that doesn't cost them a
mortgage to have the whole collection so
here comes all our stuff are on vinyl
for the first time and I got to tell you
we we have a turntable at home and it
just played this album which is one of
my dearest babies right here but just
played it on there and it all just comes
back to the very first time you heard it
[Music]
[Applause]
I think I saw you in Vegas your
residency and oh man and I was blown
away because I missed I was telling the
audience early I was so poor and I was a
kid that I couldn't go to any concerts
so I never got to everybody from school
would come back with all the merch and
the t-shirts and it would be like and
another awesome concert I miss is all
right cool but like it was one of the
things I got to see you in Vegas
it was almost better because it was just
you and your guitars and you are like
the greatest storyteller ever like I I
was captivated the entire I only used
the word captivated when describing
Meryl Streep's this is a big moment Wow
thank you but no I'm just saying like I
I was casually the entire time I was
looking at Raven arm over there together
and I was like what is happening a
guitar and he's just covered all these
songs telling stories about it and sort
of songs that you love cuz you love
covering music as well yeah
it was the most amazed
using thing I've seen I think you are
the most talented down I'm gonna send
you a big-ass box of all the t-shirts
and all the merch that we had during
those show you know don't you catch up I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this